thank you very much for the kind
introduction good morning everyone um we
are very excited uh to present you a
scroll today a
library a python library that we just
open sourced for efficient data loading
for large-scale deep learning
and today i will tell you how to use
that library to load data fast from
local and blog storage for every deep
learning framework and share it through
a data mesh how awesome is that
but
first of all i want to tell you a little
bit
about mirantix momentum because this is
important to understand why we actually
built squirrel this solution
so i'm myself leading the engineers at
mirantix
momentum
and we cope with like lots of different
ai use cases on a day by day basis
so we take the journey with our
clients from various industries from
finding
ai use cases with them researching them
[Music]
then already also building them
into an eye solution and bringing them
into production and operating them so
end to end the full chain
and our focus is a lot on deep learning
models and we try to
leverage the latest research actually in
production systems which is very
challenging
and we do this across various industries
and with very diverse data so you can
see nlp data here computer vision data
structured data
you name it
and also different ml tasks
so from
detection
classification
um learning some embeddings um and in
information material like the whole
thing um
we do for our clients
and we build a very flexible
stack to cope with all these data and ml
challenges in our projects
and
since we are building very
state-of-the-art deep learning models
usually these models are large they need
a lot of data so you have to
feed
these beasts of computation graphs
with huge amounts of data very
efficiently
so in a nutshell you get some raw data
either from clients or
from some public data sets you prepare
it so it's nice juicy and tasty for your
model
and then you feed it to your model and
let it train so it learns the tasks and
squirrel is about
the later step so taking the training
data and feeding it to your model
training
at maximum efficiency
so if you're doing this naively and you
might
started training a new machine
learning model
on
the deep learning framework of your
choice in the cloud you um
might experience some
long training process
and maybe your cloud bill goes up pretty
quickly um and you pop up your nvidia
sme
and have a look what your gpu is doing
what the training is doing and you
see a behavior like this
um so your gpu utilization jumps around
quite a bit
so you can't make um
use of the um gpu hardware um all the
time
um so
this should be the ultimate goal to keep
that
gpu busy because you're paying a lot of
money
to to basically rent these machines in
the cloud or even use them on prem
so
what might happen is
you have these
three very abstract steps of first
loading so loading it from a disk or
loading downloading your data from a
cloud a specific sample then preparing
it for the model training and then
copying it over to the gpu memory
and
if you are not um
investigating some um yeah
parallelization you would do this
sequentially but in optimal scenario you
want to pack this together
in an asynchronous way so the gpu is
always busy
so
let's imagine you have like a
use case
from medical imaging
so this is a histopathology images um a
very standard he stand image um it's
fairly large so these images are like
200k by 200k pixels
so not your average um
i don't know nist image that you you
have in your research project
um
but a fairly large image and what you
usually do is you take a sliding window
and to each of these window slides you
apply a neural network which then
predicts the class that you want for
example background or tumor or non-tumor
and if you want to train such a model
you have to feed it one of these windows
and then it has to predict the task
so if you are doing this naively you
would slice up the image and you would
get billions and billions of small
files
or
these windows if you store them locally
good luck opening this folder
in
in your file browser
or if you're storing it in the cloud and
you're trying to download it for example
from a cloud bucket
again you already pay lots of money just
for downloading all these small files
because you pay per file downloaded
if you store them in charts or just
leave them in one large image
um or in a format like tsar you um have
the issue that you might want to shuffle
your data
um but
if you just
take like windows
slide by slide by by moving the the
window over the image
um you have like very correlated images
and since the image is so huge uh you
will not get a lot of
randomness in here
um
moreover if you get new data what do you
do um
basically interleaving the new and old
data set do you want to copy it
lots of questions that you are con that
you are facing which leads to um to
engineering efforts that you have to add
to your project
um and these challenges they reoccur
and
now your model is trained and
it might not work that well so here you
see this red marker and
usually models don't work that well
in these regions because yeah some
um someone painted on the actual image
and um removed some of the important
features so you might want to debug the
model and
retrieve the specific patches
that lead to model failure but if you're
using some data formats or slice
everything up
then you have to find
this particular crop again
and for that you need metadata
now the question is how do you store the
metadata how do you link all this
together you can do this like in a data
frame store it to a disk
or like a csv file to a database but all
of this is custom and gets hacky pretty
quickly and you have to build that
yourself
so lots of questions
arise
and there are different
frameworks out there which are all great
for their purpose and they try to ease
parts of this
process so you have
for example tensorflow data or python
data to load
your data into your
model basically when using these
frameworks
but the speed and also the the
capabilities are very limited
and then there are frameworks that try
to solve these challenges by either
providing some additional abstractions
um or
um providing their own data format like
active loop or
hub from active loop web data sets or um
hugging face or ffcg
um
but then you have this um
challenge you might want to share your
data between
your members
of your project or between teams
and there are solutions by hugging face
or intake for that
and if you want to pre-compute features
there's like feast or hops works um or
if you want to um
have like
faster data transforms like faster data
augmentation then you might want to use
nvidia dolly but all of these frameworks
they do one particular thing and they do
it very good
but if you have to cope with all these
different ml use cases then using these
frameworks together
is pretty cumbersome
and they lack certain features that we
would like to have in our projects
um so our journey of actually
finding the right framework
was pretty intense so we started with
using raw files
this was obviously very slow especially
if you have
the use case that i showed before
and the reusability of the data loading
code was super low to non-existent
then we switched to tf records but
shortly later we also switched to pi
torch
and
pie charge and
tf records they work together but
it's not a very
pleasuring experience and since you
don't have an index
these debugging of the
ml models also get very cumbersome
then we move to tsar so is an excellent
framework
for
storing tensors in in chunks
but this leads to many many files in the
cloud many connect
connections and cloud costs
and we try to um to optimize the desire
library to make this more efficient but
the engineering efforts they just
escalated so this was not a fit for us
as well
and then we tried out some um more
narrow libraries
we looked at web data sets
but it uses native file formats by
default and this brings its own
challenge
challenges and you have the painful ml
debugging again
and then we tried hub good for images
but didn't work so well with text
then we tried hugging phase which uses
pi error under the hood not so good for
images but for text
and then ffcv
again good for images not so good for
text and we have large data sets so we
can't store them just on the disks and
this is just not provided by ffcv
so there was no solution for us
until now so we collected the key
requirements
that
we need from our past experience
and we came up that we want something
which is very efficient and doesn't
produce a lot of cost just by
downloading the data
we want to keep the gpu always
utilized and load only the stuff from
the remote
place that is actually needed for
training and nothing more
it should be easy to use
and we don't want this issue anymore of
having unnecessarily connections
moreover we have this very different use
cases and different data modalities so
the solution should be flexible and we
learned it the hard way there's not one
format that solves everything so we need
something which is flexible can cope
with different formats
and also easily can handle new formats
if they arise and multi-modality should
be a first citizen
so if you have like a sample here which
is
illustrated by dictionary you want to
have an image next to text to metadata
but also your your labels here and don't
need like very specific data structures
to to store these different kinds of um
data
moreover
the solution should not
replace
frameworks that are already great it
should integrate with these frameworks
and make them even better
and um it
should be also very um good for rapid
prototyping and not be a beast that you
have to
get trained on for 10 years
and since we have
lots of small teams that collaborate a
lot we
also thought about um data sharing
between these teams so if somebody
prepared
a data set created it this person might
want to share it with another team
and if you do this with a central hub
then you have a single point of failure
you have to invest in a ops team that
runs this platform and if it doesn't
work your company might stop
so we wanted to go for a centralized
system and identified that there should
not be a central point of failure it
should be very lightweight to operate
the system
and
since we
want to have it
decentralized people should also
operate their part of the infrastructure
themselves in a self-serve fashion
and
also the agreement on the
basically standards between the
different teams should be also
governed
in a distributed way
so
we didn't found a solution for us
not a single one and also not a
combination of different frameworks that
solved this for us
so
we built it on our own and here's
squirrel it's now open source and it's a
library to share load and transform data
in a collaborative flexible and
efficient way
so to understand what this squirrel is
squirrel contains primarily three
abstractions
so the foundation of everything are the
iter streams it has streams in a
nutshell are just chainable iterators
with a neat api to do so
then the next layer are drivers drivers
let you
read and write different data formats
from local and remote places
and implement
different
interfaces on them for example an
interstream interface so you can load
data from one specific data format and
then get a standardized data stream
interface back
and now the sherry on top is the catalog
so the catalog is a dictionary like data
structure that maintains all the
different data sources that you
subscribe to in the data mesh and lets
you
access all the different
instances of drivers
and from there also data streams
so how does this now look in code so
let's start with the iter streams
so here we have this list one two three
and we put it into an iterable source
object
and now you have this
very convenient uh
dot like api
where you can chain with two um
um basically an um
yeah
in a callback onto it which locks these
values in our case to an ml flow server
now the next step would be
um adding plus one like in a map
function with this lambda that is here
defined
the next step would be an async map so
the same you square the the value but
now this is done in parallel in
different
threads basically and the last step is
filtering um
your pipeline by everything which is
dividable by two
and now you can use um the result and um
basically ingest from that in our case
here a very simple example in a for loop
but imagine now you can pipe it to your
um yeah deep learning framework
um and these chainable
iterators are very flexible so now you
have seen
first i might lock my um throughput
to an experiment tracking server but
then i do some transformations of my
data
and
here in the example that you see on the
left
the parallelization is done in threads
but you can also
leverage
processes
or dali if you want to go to the gpu
or if you have like super crazy data
augmentations imagine you have like 3d
um elastic deformations that you want to
do uh
online while training you can offload
this to a das cluster
and then
you can chain other functionality on top
of it which
have some short ends like filtering
batching and all the standard stuff that
you usually
need but be careful this is a very
powerful api and the parameters they
matter so here's an example so you have
an iterable source with 5000 values you
shuffle these in an in memory buffer and
then ingest from it and if you look at
the correlation of the values in
the stream that you get back and you can
see that especially in the beginning the
values are very correlated but why is
that the case yeah you set the wrong um
parameters your initial buffer is too
low
so
um you get some correlation so be
careful if you deviate from the standard
parameters
it's powerful but you should know what
you're doing
let's now move to the second part of
scroll which are the drivers
so drivers let you
load and write
for from different data formats locally
and from remote
um our preferred data format is message
pack
it's very small and very fast to
deserialize which is pretty cool um and
we use fspec under the hood to enable
loading from local and remote places
so here you can see three examples
um here in the first example we take the
message pack driver and from a local
folder we basically create an item
stream
and now we can use it like on the
previous slide
but you can do the same with jsonl
um and since we are having fs back you
can do this also from a remote place
um but there it doesn't end
we also have integrations with other
frameworks for example with hugging face
we can directly ingest from a hugging
phased
data set but on steroids
but what happens now if you
have a data format this is not support
supported by scroll yet we are using the
amazing plugin framework
to
let you extend scroll
so let me show you an example
um
imagine you have like a graph database
this is now very mocked up
and you implement a class which inherits
from the ita driver interface
you give it a name so it can be later
also
addressed
and
your
this get it
method
which instantiates it's an iterable
source and in our case
takes like random works from our graph
and returns this in an iterator
and now
you're already done
and to make this
usable in squirrel you can either
register it
directly via the plugin manager
or
if you want to distribute your driver
you can register it like in a
classic plugin fashion via your setup by
entry points
so now people
ask us all the time yeah this is all
nice looking but
how fast is it actually so we did like a
small benchmark to show you is this
actually fast enough
uh so let's start with images so ffcv
for example is a library
that
tries to be very fast at loading images
from
a local place
but there are also other libraries that
try to solve similar things
and here we are loading a very standard
data set c for 100
onto the gpu and you can see that the
samples that you have on your gpu per
second
with squirrel
are more or less
the same as with ffcv
but now what happens if you want to go
remote load from a remote
gcp or s3 bucket or a database whatever
this is not possible with ffcv
but with some other frameworks but
squirrel is much faster here
but
what is now about text because we want
to
be able to load different kinds of
modalities
so let's now load wiki text 103
again locally scroll
really shines here um and if you go
remote
the same
so you get really high speed
for different modalities
and it doesn't really matter if you load
locally or remote in both cases it's
very fast
but what
if this is not fast enough for you
you might have like very expensive data
transformations
so you can leverage different frameworks
to make the transformations faster
so you can use torch vision pipelines or
numpy you can jit compile your
transformation similar what also ffcv
does or if you want to go full in you
can offload your
computation to dali and
let it transform on the gpu which is
even more faster so here you see an
example with a very simple pipeline and
the performance on different frameworks
let me now come to the
cherry on the top the catalog or the
data sharing functionality
so
here we figured out
the concept that we actually want is a
data mesh so a team
has
a prepared data set and it wants to
offer this data set as a product to
other teams
um and
you can think of it they get kind of a
capsule
and the interfaces in these capsules are
standardized it's more like a contract
how to load data and how to serve data
to others
um but in this capsule you can do
whatever you want this is basically the
product that you're building your
like
team ip more or less for example
transforming the your data and then
serving it to others
however this is more like a
concept
and more like an organizational
philosophy which was populated by
thoughtworks and mckinsey and others
but there's no real opinionated open
source implementation
out there for machine learning that
helps you
actually realizing this mesh
um but more like um standard solutions
that people try to
plug together to
to bring up this vision but there's an
implementation now which is squirrel and
let me guide you through it
what it actually does
so
you can
take this catalog object
and
retrieve a dictionary like structure
from it from all the data sources that
you
already subscribed to
and here you can
for example access imagenet if somebody
else hosts it and
get the heater stream directly from this
imagenet dataset and start training
and we thought that there should be
three different ways how to share data
the first one is within a project so you
have a code base
so why not use the python api so you
instantiate a new catalog object which
is empty you describe your source for
example which drivers do i want to use
what are basically the arguments from
where to load it and some metadata and
design it to some id with some version
so these sources are versionized
and now we implemented a set api on top
of the catalog so you can
do different joins of catalogs for
example here in this example the
default catalog that you subscribe to
and your custom catalog in your project
and you get a unified catalog to access
all these data sets
if you want to share data between
projects
we suggest to do this via a python
package so we are already in the python
ecosystem so why not use the deployment
mechanism of python itself
so
for that you have to implement a plugin
hook um like here in this example which
lists you all the sources that you want
to distribute
and now
you um
add the specific hook to your setup pi
like you always do with plugi
and distribute the whole thing as a
python package and if somebody installs
your python package for example via pip
install then they already get all the
data sources that you provided
via your package
if you have like a continuous delivery
pipeline for machine learning you might
not
want to generate python code and
pass it between steps
that's why you can also serialize your
catalog as a yaml file
and then um scan
specific locations um for these yaml
files and um
yeah create this catalog object again
from it
and this is especially um
interesting if you have like a whole um
machine learning pipeline end to end
and you created
a data set in one step and want to pass
it to the next step for example and have
this whole process
documented more or less and versioned
so now you've seen these three api
levels and let me show you an end-to-end
example so you see
what is the full thing
so let's train the beast
on imagenet so the first step is to get
your catalog from your
standard subscriptions
access imagenet and get the driver
object so this is loaded in a lazy
loading fashion
so now you want to get a um item stream
from it
and this driver defined several um
splits so we want to get the training
split
and since we are training in a
distributed way you might have different
nodes for training but on each node
there might also be different workers
that do the training in parallel
so instead of downloading the whole data
set on all nodes and all workers we
provide hooks to split the data set
already before downloading it to the
specific machine
after
comes the shuffling of the samples so
imagine you have now a stream of samples
and
this stream gets now shuffled in a
window of 100 samples
next is applying some runtime transforms
so here we transform the image
and return a tuple basically
finally
we want to pre-fetch this whole stream
in an asynchronous way
and then batch it together in batches of
64.
and now you can continue with what you
do all the time so here's some soider
code uh it might look different for the
deep learning framework of your choice
but you have some trainer and you can
pass your just iterator to it and train
your model
and this is basically it this is an
end-to-end example how to use
squirrel in your
training code
so why should you use scroll now so
first of all
we
think the api is just fun to use which
is a great asset for us
moreover you have a lot of functionality
to prevent gpu stalling you have like
pre-fetching you have this asynchronous
transforms you have these key hooks
and more everything to keep your machine
busy and get everything out of it
moreover you don't have to trash what
you already built but you can continue
using your preferred frameworks but now
on
steroids finally
we provide one of the first
implementations of the data mesh concept
for deep learning and are very excited
for your feedback
so
now it's your turn if i sparked your
interest
you can find
squirrel on pipeline and also on conda
we provide
a data mesh node with some
squirrel data sets already
also give us some love on on github
and if you need any support then join
our slack channel and meet our amazing
scroll developer team
and i guess now you have some questions
thanks
[Applause]
thank you yes you have lots of questions
why is it where is it much faster than
other frameworks what is the trick under
the hood
there are many tricks
i would say
um
one
one
interesting thing is message pack is
quite fast
and we do a lot of things in an
asynchronous fashion
which makes it even faster
thank you
loading data requires a combination of
cpu and i o bounded tasks the former
blocks of the gil how does the squirrel
mitigates this
the user can decide
so you can separate
the cpu and i o bond tasks so that
you can utilize both in the um best way
and you're very freely
to
to decide whatever fits your specific
use case and if that is not enough then
just offload it on a das cluster and
just
put a lot of compute on it and then it
should work
fingers crossed
a nice talk nice talk thank you uh when
showing the benchmarks i was wondering
how you made sure that for the other
frameworks you used the most efficient
implementation
um
we didn't we use the default parameters
of the frameworks so we didn't hype uh
did hyper parameter optimizing for all
these different frameworks but since
these are very preliminary um
[Music]
benchmarks i wouldn't um put too much
interpretation into it we are right now
preparing a more elaborate uh benchmark
so you can see all the different um
yeah knobs that you can turn to to make
it even faster
just out of curiosity how did you come
up with the name squirrel
very good question so all of our
software solutions at mirantix momentum
have
animal names so we have school but we
also have for example chameleon which is
our computer vision solution or we have
a parrot which is our nlp solution and
so on so we have like different um
yeah animal names and squirrel in
particular there are several reasons
but one punch line is it's a data
infrastructure library which doesn't
drive your nuts
do you use a job queueing system or what
is your approach to
fully utilize all gpus without idle time
um
i think i i dig a little bit into it
like you can use this splitting of cpu
and io bound tasks you can use a dash
cluster multi-processing multi-threading
depending on the individual step
and
um yeah that's basically it if you if
you want more go dolly like you can
combine all these frameworks uh within
squirrel to get the most performance out
of your setup and since we have very
different ml use cases and data that we
are coping we also have
different setups for different tasks but
since the api is very easy to use people
love
putting together their pipelines for
their specific ml problems
thank you
does the squirrel support splitting
streams for example for n cross field
validation
um not by itself but if you want you can
use
[Music]
this to method and
plug in
whatever
callback that you want
we do agree that most aspects of
squirrel are not limited to deep
learning but might make sense also for
other data processing flows
um
also a good question so we have heard
this already a few times so we built
this for actually deep learning uh
training but of course you have this
process or this problem or challenge of
getting data onto your machine in a very
fast way in also different scenarios
and it's also possible to use scroll
there because it's
data
or yeah it's a framework agnostic
but this was not an intentional
basically design but would be happy to
see how you use it in in other creative
use cases
um yeah that would be cool to learn
thank you does it also works with
multiple gpus
uh yes of course that's why we have
these
these hooks for example if you um
want to distribute your training then
you can use the hooks to
feed the samples that are for example
for one specific gpu just to just gpu
and you don't have to like download it
for each gpu and then discard most of
the data um in memory
thank you uh next question could you
describe what was the issue with pi
arrow what was the slow specifically did
you reach the dev team
so
pi error itself
is more like a column format
and if you are not just reading one of
these columns but uh want to
in a very fast way read um
[Music]
like rows of it
um it doesn't provide you with lots of
functionality here
and if you have tensors like images also
the dc realization
was not that fast as far as i remember
i think the next one is kind of a
duplicate but uh what exactly explains
the higher throughput observed web
square row
yeah i think that's a duplicate
have you been able to measure effective
increased gpu usage through
parallelization with ether streams
um
to be honest like
right now these inter streams are so
fast that we
can load much more data than we can
actually process on the gpu
so it's just the maximum
do you plan on evaluating bigger data
sets
yes so this was just a very primary
preliminary evaluation just to show you
something but
a larger evaluation is in the pipeline
someone wants to know if you're going to
share the slides
no but i think the talk will be uh
online right okay
uh the last question is uh can you
define a own way how to split the data
set easily i'm not sure understand it
actually
i think it's again a duplicate you can
you can provide these key hooks to do
that
thank you very much please let's think
[Applause]
you